merry Christmas joyeux Noël en français
un petit message de 14 caractères
seulement mais qui vote aujourd'hui très
cher il s'agit en fait du premier SMS au
monde envoyé il y a tout juste 30 ans en
décembre 1992 et il sera vendu demain
pour aux enchères en France mise à prix
100000 € là je repartira avec un
certificat de propriété et l'argent
récolté c'est la bonne nouvelle sera
reversée intégralement à l'agence des
Nations Unies pour les réfugiés
sous le regard ahuri de dizaines de
migrants le 4 4 de l'armée enchaîne les
dérapages dans ce champ boule
hier matin c'est militaire de la mission
Vigipirate s'amusant toute décontraction
mais le conducteur perd rapidement le
contrôle est le véhicule s'embourbe
au moment de l'accident il était seul
mais il n'a pas paniqué il a appliqué
des technique de survie apprises à
l'armée et à lui-même réussi à stopper
l'hémorragie avec sa ceinture
un garrot avec sa ceinture
bien la douleur les urgentistes ne
reviennent pas malgré le choc il trouve
même la force de plaisanter avec elle
Bérézina total le journaliste qui suit
cette cette affaire raconte qu'il y a eu
des tensions dans soupe avec des
migrants tension avec les CRS qui se
trouvait pas loin parce qu'il ne il ne
venait pas prêter main-forte justement
aux militaires soldats étaient en train
de les aider mon finalement ça c'est
fini au bout de plusieurs heures de
galère
ce sont des amandes parce qu'on vient la
avec le véhicule on est interdit de
donner de l'eau et de la nourriture et
là il y a des il y a des véhicules de
l'armée payer avec de l'argent public
qui font des dérapages le bidonville
près de vie de repos de cuisine et passé
un exilé voilà le repas de fête facturer
4 € servi à des enfants dans une école
en Angleterre ses photos partagées en
ligne par un parent d'élève suicide des
commentaires d'un internaute totalement
ou très des prisonniers ferai une
émotion lance Hervé ça c'est vraiment
dégoûtant sincèrement je ne donnerai
même pas ça à manger à mon chien fasse
la direction s'est excusé et promets de
rembourser l'intégralité des repas et
qu'est-ce qu'on a la place du foie gras
lors du jambon blanc
en tout cas
moi il y a pas longtemps
végétal qui donne envie
alléchant
c'est romantique
en le leader mondial du hamburger est
prêt à tout vraiment à tout pour vendre
ses sandwichs et paraître paraître en
tout cas lutter contre l'embonpoint des
consommateurs regarder sont des vélos
des vélos dynamo désormais quelques-uns
de ces fast-food comme ici en Chine et
puis on peut même temps recharger son
portable et manger
un autre que j'aimerais bien faire
de la reine Élisabeth de l'année
prochaine
après les
fêtes de Noël une photo
maintenant le premier ministre avec 17
personnes à proximité le 15 mai 2020
dans le jardin de
2 personnes maximum de foyer différents
viennent de donner des chiffres en vie
réelle alors attention de frissonner pas
mais après deux doses de fizer
l'efficacité n'ai que 2,19 pourcents au
palais d'efficacité de 2 semaines après
de dos avec Astra Zeneca l'efficacité nu
après de dos donc vraiment contre micro
de dos et suffit pas pour faire fuir ce
qu'il harcèle dans la rue c'est trop
Annese inventé la technique du dindon
démonstration
cette vidéo de Sarah la crieuse comme
elle se surnomme sur les réseaux sociaux
a été vu 5 million de fois
par contre est-ce que là je suis
protégée là ça remonte heureusement on
remonte avec une 3e 2de on va remonter à
77 % d'efficacité on va être à 73 %
d'efficacité avec Astra Zeneca une
question tarot les chefs d'entreprise
que faire des salariés qui ne serai pas
en mesure de présenter un pas sanitaire
faudra-t-il les mettre en télétravail
pour les postes éligibles suspendre leur
contrat et leur salaire où les placer en
congé
alors je peux venir aider
pas moins de 3 personnes sont
nécessaires pour porter les 30 kg de
serpent
[Musique]
tu sais. On été soumis par les
partenaires sociaux à la ministre du
Travail Élisabeth borne à l'issue de la
réunion de ce matin voilà ce qu'elle
déclare rien et que tu es à ce stade ce
qui ressort des échanges c'est que les
organisations syndicales ils sont pas
favorables et que les organisations
patronales sont réservés pour les mails
on l'a dit mais vous vous rendez compte
sur vous détruisez la vie des gens ils
en tant que faire la réponse automatique
suivez mais vous détruisez la vie des
gens en faisant ça
ça peut être un style ah non c'est bon
ça que porter comme ça je peux créer une
tendance
de
la musique
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]